- [Mark] Okay, Rosa.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Rosa, tell me where you are from.
Where, where did you grow up?
- [Rosa] I grew up in Los Angeles,
California in South Central.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- [Rosa] In the beginning my
mum wasn't there, she was...
I had to find out later
that she was addicted
to some type of drug that kept her away.
- [Mark] So mum was doing
drugs and where is dad?
- In the beginning,
like my first few years like
six to seven dad wasn't there.
Dad was doing the same thing.
- [Mark] So both parents were doing drugs
and they were out of the picture?
- So I found out, yeah.
I jumped different places. I
have been in fostered homes,
different family members houses,
I've been almost everywhere.
Yeah, until my dad got
himself back together
and he came and got us,
it's five of us, yeah.
- [Mark] And what age was that when he...
- I was like six or seven.
- [Mark] So six or seven he
came back in the picture?
- Yes.
- [Mark] But between...
- Before that I was
moved different places.
- [Mark] Wow. And how was
your life after dad came back?
- Yeah, in the beginning
it was okay, it was good.
Until things changed up.
Mum wasn't there so, in
substitute for our mum,
dad will have somebody else,
as things things changed up.
I guess theirs didn't work anymore.
Once they got broken things changed up.
Dad attitude even
changed, it was different.
So it...
the mood in the house was more down
or unhappy.
More...yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have brothers and sisters?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How many?
- I have three brothers and
one sister. I am number four.
- [Mark] So how was your
childhood, generally?
How would you describe it?
Was there abuse?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What kind?
- I have been whipped.
When I was jumping from different
places I got disciplined.
Some for their own personal reasons
cause I didn't do something the way
they wanted it to be done.
I could have forgot a piece
of paper on the ground
when I was supposed to make sure
the whole floor was cleaned up.
Stuff like that.
I've been, I don't, I don't
know if you would say malicious,
I've been touched by a family,
it wasn't believed, they didn't
believe me when it came out.
And I heard it, that bothered me
especially cause I knew it was true.
That type of abuse
which caused me later on in school to...
I don't wanna say be abusive
cause I was not just beating on people
but I was the fighting type.
I fought.
- [Mark] What age were
you when you left home?
- I was...
what? Four... like 15 I would say.
15 I, I left.
I went to jail and all that.
Yeah, 15 I ran away and was gone.
- [Mark] Where did you go?
- I didn't travel around the
world but I traveled around,
say all this neighborhood
like familiar places
I bounced around myself
and went places I could
have met new people.
- [Mark] How did you survive?
What did you do for money?
- I took it at that time.
I done things I didn't
wanna do at that time.
Yeah, and then...
I, I changed. I, I took it.
I did what was needed to be done.
Yeah especially at that
time I wasn't by myself,
I was with my baby daddy.
So, I was coat pinched I
felt like I had to do things.
But after I lost my babies
and I moved away
after I left my place
we went to jail, went to a placement,
and later got my own place,
lived out on my own I changed.
God changed me. He gave me
a different way of thinking.
I see life differently,
especially when my son came.
My son changed my life.
I was 19
when I had him
and he changed everything.
Cause I felt like I, I had to...
what I do he gonna see.
So I had to be an example
especially because his dad wasn't
it wasn't a for sure thing and
we knew that in the beginning
it wasn't a for sure thing so
I went along with knowing that
I may or may not have
this person by my side.
- [Mark] So you, you don't
know who his father is?
- No, I know who his
father is, but I'm saying
I still made a decision of keeping my baby
or like that... living life
if it was just me and my son.
- [Mark] Awesome. Did,
did you raise your son?
- Yes, until I messed up
and he got taken from me.
- [Mark] At what age, was he?
- He was nine months
when he first got taken.
And it took a while but I got him back.
And, after I got him back a
year later I had a sister.
I kept her.
She was, I lost her it
was her first birthday.
Yeah, on her birthday.
And then,
I haven't been back to
(inaudible)
- [Mark] So you, you lost both
kids at her first birthday?
- Yeah.
Yeah I did.
They have been away from
me from me ever since then
I have been back and forth for seeing them
or stuff like that
but I haven't fully gotten
them back in my custody yet.
And luckily or gladly by the grace of God
they are with family right now.
At first there was AI and the system,
but it has got to the point
where they are with family
and they can stay with family
until I get myself together.
- [Mark] Oh, good. So
what is your drug today?
(sighs heavily)
- Today, surprisingly
so it is crack cocaine.
That's crazy cause I used to hate crack
because I ended up finding out
that's what mum and dad did.
And that's what...
that was the reason for
mum and dad being away.
I hated it.
The people couldn't smoke it
home around me or anything.
Even when I moved, first moved down here.
They had to wait till I walk out the room
in order to light it.
That's how much respect they had for me
but I ain't hate the smell or anything.
Just from knowing what it does or...
I held a feeling,
a bad feeling towards it
because I knew that's what my...it kept...
that's what kept mum and dad away.
And then, in a midst of living down here,
I started smoking crystal again.
That changed everything.
It.. I was going to school at first.
I stopped going to school.
I even, didn't even... I
stopped leaving my room.
My baby daddy was there with me at first,
but when he left and it was
just me everything changed.
For a while I ain't leaving my room.
I made people bring it to me
everything I needed, literally.
- [Rosa] And then I
started coming out my room
just in my building and won't go outside.
When I started crack, I had, I had to
get content
or okay enough with going outside
because I, what do they
call it? Third party.
I didn't want nobody else
going to get my stuff for me
cause of how people are,
especially if they do the same job.
It don't come back the same way.
I, so I had to figure out
a way to do it on my own.
And for the last two and a half years,
yeah, I've been doing meth.
I hate it.
I really do.
I don't know if I'm cursing now,
but this drug is a mother fucker.
This drug has changed my life.
I miss my babies.
That's how I know it's so
strong, because its like...
I'm stuck.
I have been stuck down
here for a long time.
I don't even go that far. Distance is...
Even being right here on this
street is far from where I am.
I became antisocial.
I don't even like to even bring
them up in the conversation
cause it's too much.
But...
it kills me because I say I
smoke to stay out of my head
because when I get to
thinking my thoughts are bad.
Because I'm emotionally and
mentally fucked up right now.
Based on relationships I've been in.
(foreign language)
- But before I can catch it
or grab it it was too late and
my emotions are found
out became overwhelmed
I never knew that your
emotions can be this strong.
That's why I love God or I'm
glad to know there is a God
because He the only one I
know or can help me with me.
And I hate that I know that
and I'm still not doing
what I need to do to be where I should.
But
I, I still have faith though.
And I...even in amidst
everything I speak of Him.
I try to speak it to existence.
So I know in due time this that
I'm going through will flip.
I call it being flipped.
I'll go back to the good.
Like that's the life outside
of this, is me going to church,
me following God's footsteps.
That's what I want, that's what I need.
I once was there. I need that. I miss it.
But it's crazy, dad. This
really got me really stuck
its hard to just... and I never knew that.
And I hate that I had to get
into this to find that out.
But I pray and I believe
that by the grace of God
before my heart stops beating,
I will be able to live that
life I will be able to flip.
I want to see me like that
cause I know once I stop this,
I'm going to be able
to call myself a woman.
I don't see myself as that right now,
because I know things that
should be, be undone is not.
But I, I want to see that.
Cause I'm going to be bad
I'm going to be beaut...
I just want to see I wanna feel it.
I want to supply the heart...
I want to supply the the
time heart peace on earth
where I can say I was happy.
And that's the main priority.
- And I guess I'm going
through this to find out
what was it that I
didn't have strong enough
to keep me like that or keep me in there.
Cause I thought I was but
obviously you see, I'm not.
I never see this coming,
I never expected it or anything
especially crack cocaine.
I had to take a hit
before I got over here,
I was trying to take a hit
before I came in here, like...
This drug is deep.
Even though I feel weak,
I know God is strong.
So I know in due time
that before my heart stops
and He calls me home,
I will stop this and be able to live a...
a faithful life.
Especially because I
have somebody in my life
that who I may... I love him.
But this drug right here I see is...
I wish I knew Him or
I had Him before this.
He I, He I wanna, He's
the one I wanna marry.
I seriously want to
spend my life with Him.
I want His last name like, I seriously do.
And it's deep, we have
been together four years.
And a lot of it, is me.
I'm fucking up.
And for some reason He still
loved me and He still do.
Especially for the things He don't know.
I just wish... especially
because of this relationship
and my kids, my babies.
I just...
I just wish it would come
to an end sooner than later.
And I seriously hate that it's here.
For real.
It's something I got to...
its something that's missing
or I gotta figure it out.
And I hope I do, sooner than later.
For real.
(inaudible)
But I am tired, though.
And I'm just keep saying
that until it happen.
I'm keep saying that until it happen.
Only God knows how I really feel.
I miss God, I miss my
babies, I, I miss it.
I miss the love.
This shit is killing me. All
these, these people is wicked.
This people is wicked.
And for me to be around them
it's like I'm being, its like
I'm okay with it or it's like
I'm even becoming it got me... no.
I don't want to die like that.
I do not want this to be the
way what they tell my babies,
"Her mummy left."
I don't want this to be it.
I need it to be something different.
I need, I need them to, to
know something different.
And honestly I try not to, I hate
even to say that cause it's
just like how can you say
how can I say I love Him
if I'm doing I'm doing.
That fucks with me. But
I hate...I loved Him.
I really do.
I love him. I hate that
I can't even be there.
So it's like damn, this drug is true.
Life is, life is real, life is serious.
You really got to be careful
on what you do and how you do it.
Cause you can just..something
could so easily like...wow.
But I have, I got faith though
that I'll be with my babies again
and that I'll be a wife
and have it... you know, I'll
be able to have it, you know,
the fairytale is ream that is
not impossible to have though.
I want it and I know I can have it.
God said I can.
Anything is possible through Christ Jesus.
And my one wish, my number
one wish and my prayer is:
- [Rosa] God Please, I want
to head out before I die.
Whatever it takes in that keep me strong.
Please let me live through this,
to be able to have that before I go.
- [Mark] All right, Rosa.
Thank you so much for, for coming in.
- You are welcome.
- [Mark] good luck in getting...
- Thanks.
- [Mark] in getting your life together.
This is deep.